deswegen würde ich mal sagen das ist bis
jetzt mein favourit produkt was zurzeit
existiert oder favorite produkt china
schon mäßig gesehen
ist das ein müll alter von poco diese
scheiße hier nie wieder kolportiert man
ab geburt kommt komplett durch scheiße
das ist das hier die schmeißen wenn
dieses video wer jetzt leute schmeißen
verdreckten tisch auf malta es geht man
kann sich ja nicht mal hier drunter
setzen jetzt muss ich mich erst mal ein
bisschen sammeln ich habe keine ahnung
ob das bild gut aussieht ist mir
scheißegal ich bin auch gerade auch
bringt natürlich bei meinen eltern zu
hause hier in meinem zimmer in meinem
anleihen es ist ja eigentlich mein
schönes thema aber dieses zimmer
es ist ein verein zur katastrophe und
dann hat dieser tisch den ich mir geholt
habe das ist ein absoluter müll tisch
100 euro oder soll ich denn gekostet ich
breche ihm gleich auseinander nach dem
video wir ehrlich dann kann ich hier
keine videos mehr drehen kann ich nur
noch in köln machen damit aber etwas
gedacht und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video ich hoffe natürlich geht es
gut ich hatte eben so bock darauf dieses
video zu drehen
ja und dann hat mir dieser preis tisch
das eigentlich versaut regelfall hier
oben schon raus ok auf jeden fall kam
vor einigen tagen das video ich habe
alle apple-produkte bayerisch bestellt
unter anderem auch eine fake apple watch
und zwar genau diese hier hatte man das
original hatte geht es nämlich schon
muss genau diese hier ich habe mich mit
der materie jetzt ein bisschen weiter
beschäftigt und es handelt sich hierbei
um die apple world series
das ist aktuell die neues auf dem markt
und in dem video habe ich schon gesagt
leute passt auch das produkt das macht
auf mich und wirklich cool ein hoch ist
hat 18 euro gekostet was wirklich nicht
viel ist wenn ich das mit der smart
watch vergleiche die ich vor zweieinhalb
von zwei jahren ungefähr bei uns
bestellt haben dann ist die um welten
besser und es haben wirklich sehr vielen
kommentar geschrieben dass ich doch
bitte mal ein ausführliches video
darüber machen soll
und ich habe selber extrem bock drauf
deswegen habe ich mir hier auch mal eine
original apple watch des ios 5 als man
uns gesagt besorgt und möchte diese
beiden mal vergleichen
ich bin euch hier super gerne mann
detailaufnahmen davon 1 damit ihr euch
auch mal so darüber im klaren sein wie
identisch diese dinge eigentlich sind
also ich muss wirklich sagen ich habe
die natürlich als ich die originale dann
in den händen gehalten hat schon so ein
bisschen verglichen und ich war total
erstaunt man kann wirklich kein unter
stecken das gibt berlin berlin bisher
leider gerade bitte das ist
unprofessionell zu video auf einem kanal
sind leugnen aber darum geht es ja auch
nicht nur ein konzept ist es ja dinge
auszupacken und das unterhaltsam war
daher auf jeden fall auch was das
gewicht angeht wir haben komplett zwei
identische exemplare mit dem einen
unterschied dieses kostet gläubig 485
euro und dieses hier 18 legen die fake
watches mal beiseite und schamlos das
originale ding an
so sieht das hier aus das ganze ist
jetzt hier mit dem passwort unterlegt
das muss ich mal kurz knacken gut dann
haben wir das auch erledigt und sind
dann hier jetzt auch direkt schon im
menü und ich muss sagen ich habe mir ja
die fake watches & schon ein bisschen
make it happy
aha die gehört nämlich ein kollege von
mir julia exercise ring dem make a lot
of russia today hat er hatte gestern
nicht so viel aktivität das sind
natürlich dann diese kleinen features
aber ihr könnt auch hier sind bei der
fei quatsch das sieht alles relativ
identisch aus natürlich reagiert jetzt
nicht so gut wie die originale das muss
man sagen aber von den apps her würde
ich schon sagen kann man auch nicht
direkt sehen dass es sich um fake
handelt wir haben jetzt ein paar schon
raus bekommen dass diese watch zum
beispiel auch den puls messen kann und
einmal darauf aufmerksam macht wenn es
vielleicht gerade nicht so sonderlich
gut aussieht mehr habe ich mir jetzt
noch gar nicht angestellt ich weiß aber
dass man natürlich auch über die apple
wolf zum beispiel musik hören kann da
weiß ich jetzt gar nicht ob das hier
ausgeht aber wir werden es natürlich
herausfinden auf dieser apple much ist
also praktisch musik gespeichert und
könnte jetzt meine er trotz verbinden um
diese musik abzuspielen ob das hier auch
geht na ja ich mag es zu bezweifeln
aber wir schauen uns das einfach mal an
dazu entsperrt ich jetzt einfach mal die
uhr und suche nach musik
[Musik]
gut dann muss man jetzt hier schon den
ersten abstrich machen also wir haben
bei dieser uhr auf einen internen
speicher zum beispiel auf dem musik
speichern kann
das heißt wenn man zum beispiel joggen
geht braucht man nur die uhr seine
airports wurden kann ordentlich loslegen
hier ist es so man kann über die uhr das
handy steuern also die musik des handys
muss allerdings immer das handy dabei
haben das heißt wir können hier keine
musik draufladen was natürlich ein
bisschen schade ist für 18 euro habe ich
das aber auch nicht anders erwartet muss
ich sagen
also ja dieses feature hier habe ich
euch auch beim letzten mal schon gezeigt
da kann man jetzt im puls messen
ich glaube das ist unnötig das jetzt
noch mal zu machen funktioniert auf
jeden fall also ähnlich wie bei der
original hört auch leute wir sind jetzt
gerade hier wieder bei der originalen
watch kann jetzt zum beispiel volkes
ablesen auf dieser uhr sind 381 songs 78
fotos insgesamt hat die eine kapazität
von 27 gigabyte und noch verfügbar sind
21 also das sind halt alles sachen die
ihr leider nicht mitbringt ok dann würde
ich sagen wir lassen die hier also die
originale jetzt erst mal so ein bisschen
links liegen ich muss nämlich auch sagen
ich bin jetzt kein experte das heißt
wenn irgendwas falsch war es mir nicht
übel an sich soll der hauptfokus ihre
auf liegen auf dem verklingen
und wir schauen uns jetzt noch mal so
ein bisschen hier die verschiedenen apps
an was man damit machen kann ob man
vielleicht sich auch eine app aus dem
appstore ziehen kann um dann halt später
ein fazit zu ziehen ob die sich meiner
meinung nach für euch lohnen könnte so
wie ich das immer mache telefonieren
geht ganz einfach über die walsh das
habe ich im letzten paar doch schon
gezeigt könnt euch gerne nochmal
anschauen möchte ich hier jetzt nicht
noch mal machen
okay leute geil das nächste feature was
ich gefunden hat ist dieses dingen und
zwar so eine art schritt messer wie
viele kilokalorien mann verbrannte und
wie viele kilometer man am tag schon
gelaufen ist dann kann ich ja mal kurz
checken ob das auch wirklich
funktioniert wir gehen wir einmal die
treppe rauf und runter ich las die uhr
am handgelenk okay hier kann man es
jetzt sehen 30 sep sind war schon hart
grad waren es komischerweise noch 13
ihr herz ganz entspannt mal die treppe
runter deutlich wird für ändern tut sich
jetzt hier leider nicht okay jetzt sehe
ich gerade
es hat sich jetzt hier auf 44 steps
erhöht das heißt das ganze dauert an
stellt man ein bisschen bis es sich
aktualisiert alles funktioniert so
halbwegs nicht ganz optimal würde ich
sagen aber es funktioniert dann schaue
ich einfach mein gott ich mache immer
wieder ab ich schaue einfach mal was das
ding noch so kann hier sehe ich jetzt
gerade eine art mac have to the new alle
an
das können wir auch gern mal
ausprobieren weil ich auch gesehen haben
in einigen videos dass man die uhr also
die originale war einfach so hinstellen
kann und dann zum beispiel als wecker
benutzen könnt das finde ich es wenn die
hier das auch kann
wir stellen meine zeit ein
[Musik]
okay wir haben auch verschiedene
klingeltöne die direkt mitgeliefert
wurden im paket wie damals bei den bei
meinem ersten handy beim ersten
schiebehandy leute mir ist aufgefallen
dass die uhr natürlich nicht richtig
ging die wollte ich jetzt nachträglich
noch einstellen
und mir ist aufgefallen dass hier sofort
noch verschiedene designs mitgeliefert
werden wenn ich euch sehr gern auch
immer einig wird hier einfach mal so
durch und will da mal ein neues aus dass
hier würde ich ziemlich kleben muss ich
sagen okay
das leben war ich habe jetzt gerade mal
dieses design ja eingestellt und ja auch
einen wecker geteilt sodass die jetzt
gleich klingeln sollte hoffe ich mal
sechseinhalb stunden später also ich
habe jetzt ein bisschen gewartet mit dem
wetter hat das irgendwie nicht so leute
letzter versuch eine minute hat er noch
dann was eigentlich der wecker gehen
wenn er dann nicht geht dann
funktioniert das ich denke mal aufgrund
des speichers nicht weil irgendwie
werden diese alarme die ich an stelle im
auge hat direkt wieder gelöscht sehr
schade irgendwie so bitte bitte jetzt
gibt es doch gar nicht geht nicht ich
weiß nicht warum ich habs jetzt ewig
ausprobiert alle angeht leider nicht
also na ja es sind so ein paar kleine
fehler irgendwie da drin
trotzdem bin ich noch überzeugt sag ich
mal so weit es geht habe ich jetzt
eigentlich alles getestet was mich
interessieren wir können hier gerne
nochmal einmal so durch gelegt wenn euch
das ein wir haben hier oben so sind
seine schreibt oder so ist das glaube
ich dann haben wir hier sogar ein
kalender den rechner zu machen der sich
sogar aus wie beim
normalen iphone oder bei der normalen
apple watch funktioniert auch den place
tor der ja theoretisch hier drauf sein
könnte habe ich jetzt leider auch nicht
gefunden also es ist uns nicht möglich
irgendwelche zusätzlichen apps wie
whatsapp oder sonstiges hier drauf zu
laden oder irgendwie ich weiß nicht ob
die jetzt zum beispiel gesehen
fussball labs wo man ergebnisse sehen
kann das geht leider nicht also die uhr
bringt ein paar apps mit alles was man
braucht wie zum beispiel rechner
kalender pulsmessung man kann darüber
telefonieren man kann darüber musik
steuern aber man braucht halt leider
immer sein handy dabei was das ganze
natürlich ein bisschen schade macht und
ja das dann in frage gestellt trotzdem
muss ich sagen in einem meiner ganzen
fisch und online-shopping erfahrung für
18 euro
ist das wirklich ein produkt was bis
jetzt unschlagbar ist also ich kann mich
nicht daran erinnern dass ich bei
irgendeiner sache nur begeistert war wie
jetzt bei der uhr also ich würde auf
jeden fall einiges damit zu machen und
vor allem für 18 euro kann man da gar
nicht meckern
deswegen würde ich hier wirklich mal
sagen das ist bis jetzt mein fell world
wish produkt was zurzeit existiert oder
favorite produkt china schon mäßig
gesehen dass die originale watch im
gesamtpaket hundertmal besser der touch
funktioniert besser die funktion
funktionelle einwandfrei aber das
überrascht ja auch keines wochen hier
ist gar nicht sagen
es ging einfach mal nur darum dieses 18
euro dingen zu testen und euch meine
meinung dazu zu sagen und falls sich
jemand gerade so eine smart watch und
falls sich jemand für so smart watch es
interessiert und nicht unbedingt 500
euro dafür ausgeben möchte erfüllt die
auch halbwegs sein zweck und man zeit
hat wirklich sehr sehr wenig also das
ist für 18 euro und unschlagbares
produkt meiner meinung nach bringt viele
coole sachen mit manchen muss ich in
frage stellen
trotzdem alles in allem würde ich sagen
hat spaß gemacht zu testen und ich hoffe
ihr konnte damit ein bisschen was
anfangen falls ihr noch mehr videos in
die richtung sehen wollt schaut euch
gerne noch die letzten an
es kommt auf jeden fall jetzt einige
noch ich habe ja auch nur kleine kopf
was für eine vorstellung zu sagen ich
bin euch hier sehr gern mal kurz ein
gutscheincode oder vielleicht auch ein
paar gutscheine die schreibe ich in die
kommentare
dann kriegt ihr dann 25 prozent rabatt
bis zum 31.10 dritten wünsche euch viel
spaß mit und ja die produkte werden wie
immer besseren verlost wobei die watch
eigentlich schon
los ist muss jan losschicken schreibt
mir sehr gerne weitere ideen und wünsche
was sie bestellen sollen und testen oder
in die kommentare
ansonsten war es das von mir und meinen
beiden apple watchers ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen